la 7è premières vacances depuis combien
de temps trois ans essayez dernière
avant combien de temps avant je pense
avant deux ans à peu près deux ans mais
en même temps c'est important les
vacances c'est une autre manière de
travailler
je peux réfléchir je peux tu notes les
trucs soit en bateau là en ce moment oui
un peu mais moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un
qui me j'ai une mémoire incroyable
et puis c'est faire n'importe quoi les
vacances c'est ça qui est bien c'est
dire j'ai sommeil c'est dormir c'est à
dire j'ai sommeil et je veux pas dormir
et tu dors pas c'est sortir jusqu'à 8
heures du matin c'est c'est fumer des
cigarettes parce que je peux quand je
joue le spectacle je fume beaucoup moins
c'est il ya une liberté incroyable
le spectacle c'est une contrainte c'est
une discipline infernale parce qu'on a
parce que le spectacle tous les jours
c'est la première ce que les gens qui
viennent voir son spectre est il n'était
pas là la veille est centrale car ça
peut arriver et ferment parce que moi
qui viens tous les jours mais
globalement bon alors ils n'ont jamais
vu le truc est pour eux si t'es pas bien
même si tu y joues la santé voilà tu
seras nul donc il faut que tu sois bien
tous les jours et tous les jours tu
arrives à un endroit et tapas de vie tes
copains le samedi le dimanche qui
travaillent donc tu vois très peu tes
copains tu vois très peu les gens mais
c'est tellement génial en même temps que
bon ça va oui oui oh non mais ça moi je
ne pourrais jamais changé je pourrais
jamais faire un autre métier je pourrai
c'est impensable c'est impensable jeu
j'aime trop ça et d'ailleurs c'est très
étrange
parce que je manque encore plus ça
qu'avant j'ai remarqué que
ça me manquait très vite
et puis et puis c'était plus en plus
important c'est peut-être le seul
endroit où je me sens pas non
on parle je suis vachement sérieux je
fais pas de blague parce que souvent
quand je fais des émissions de
télévision avant en tout cas je me
forçais à faire des blagues je me
forçais à faire des blagues parce que
j'avais l'impression que c'est comme ça
qu'il fallait les gens voulaient tu
pensais que les gens voulaient voir
comme ça ouais et je je suis pas très à
l'aise à la télévision ya plein de gens
qui me disent ah tiens on vous a vu dans
une émission vous aviez pas l'air à
l'aise et je ne suis pas à l'aise parce
que je suis pas chez moi parce que je
fais moi signe c'est le terrain je sais
pas moi
il a été bien appuyé là ça va sur la
plage
je savais n'y a pas de caméra l'acteur y
a pas un mec qui me faisait un pari je
constate qu'ils acquièrent par les
camions des jeux mais je suis comme tout
le monde ça veut dire sortie de mon cas
je me mets à jouer un personne n'a plus
envie de faire ça disons que au début
quand on disait par exemple c'est encore
mais l'a commise il allait souvent l'un
je me suis amusée je connaissais pas
tous après ça m'amusait beaucoup je me
rendais pas compte de ça et puis petit à
petit avec le temps la fraîcheur de ça
ils envie de faire ça comme c'est pas
mon métier je faisais ça pour m'amuser
j'allais à la télé tout d'un coup
j'étais plus devant le magasin était
dans la vitrine
ça me faisait des mois au bout d'un
moment ça arrêtez de me fasciner
et puis mon corps mon vrai métier c'est
pas ça et puis la télévision a beaucoup
changé mais la télévision et c'est un
problème c'est qu'à fois si tu vas à la
télé en essayant comme ça de faire des
blagues de faire le bush n'a au bout
d'un moment tu totaux caricature oui et
là ça t'énerve seulement tant de
caricatures non j'aime bien qu'on
caricature que j'aime pas c'est quand
qu'il ya une fausse vision des gens tu
vois quand on réduit les gens s'éclatent
et les bijoux et les douleurs et et puis
et puis c'est faux tu vois tu peux pas
savoir le nombre de gens qui viennent
pas me voir au spectacle heureusement il
ya beaucoup de jeunes voir ce problème
mais le nom de gens qui viennent pas me
voir parce qu'ils m'ont vu à la télé et
qui me disent ah ben moi j'ai vu bouger
malgré ça me plaît pas tu peux pas
savoir à quoi exactement
tu me fasses or le manque de gens qui
viennent me voir au spectacle qui vient
me voir après qu'ils me disent ah je ne
savais pas que c'était ça qu'on faisait
parce que la télévision dans mon cas à
moi c'est pas le cas de tous les comics
ne restitue pas du tout mon travail
parce que moi je ne suis pas drôle dans
la vidéo justice et des fois et dû
croiser des gens dans la rue ils te dis
ah ouais mais c'est moins de droit qu'à
la télé et toi tu es moins drôle mais
fait le clown fait le clown c'est pas un
comic con est un raconteur puis j'aime
bien
j'aime bien déconné mais ça c'est comme
dans la vie ça vient quand ça vient ça
je vais pas me forcer
c'est horrible de se forcer alors le
team jeudi mais je pas une machine
monsieur je sais pas moi je me
débrouille alors longtemps ça me fait de
la peine j'aime pas qu'ils disent a fait
appel au savoir ouais je vois pas ce que
tu aimes bien aussi que les gens aiment
bien tu sais tu sais pas trop comment
nous débrouiller avec ça c'est c'est
vachement compliqué et puis je te dis la
télévision a beaucoup changé aussi on
commet ben j'ai l'impression si tu veux
que que les artistes à la télévision
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont moins à
l'aise qu'avant je crois pas être le
seul
je crois que la télévision est devenue
une telle machine censée appris
énormément d'importance dans la vie des
gens maintenant labellisé absolument
avant tu avais des gens qui disaient
hier soir j'ai vu un film j'ai lu un
livre chez le spectacle maintenant ils
disent est ce que tu as vu l'émission de
dechavanne ou les michelin je sais pas
qui est même la télévision fait parler
d'elle ça veut dire que les animateurs
la télévision et un article sur dans les
journaux il ya des magazines de plus en
plus sur la télévision
les comiques sont des sketches sur la
télévision la télévision c'est devenu le
sujet d'ailleurs en bout de table
avant il y avait le père ouais et qu'il
donnait la soupe
maintenant il ya la télé cole à la place
tout perdre et va demander à la télé de
servir à sauver les gens immense comme
ça et je me demande quand ils font
d'ailleurs ça a pris alors en même temps
c'est formidable c'est une petite
publication génial et en même temps ça
en ferme tout le monde dans le même si
ça fait peur et les moins en moins de
gens qui sont marginaux par rapport à la
télé sur ton sur ton bateau tu à l'affût
la télé là non tu vois par exemple une
autre chose qui me fait penser tu me
parler de moi et de la télévision
il ya plein de gens qui que ça énerve
parce que des fois à la télé je parle de
tout et tu donnes ton avis sur tout et
ils disent ah mais suite à une casse les
bombers ils parlent tous de tout ils
s'intéressent ils à un avis sur tout et
mais je trouve que c'est formidable
d'avoir d'être curieux ça veut pas dire
parce que j'ai envie de parler tous que
ce que je dis est intelligent je peux
dire mais comme j'en dis souvent le
problème mais mon coach on trouve en
face d'un team tu te poses des questions
surtout tu réponds et que tu le journal
ex tu t'intéresses si bien s'intéresser
à tous j'ai pas envie d'être un abruti
qui dit ah non monsieur ou en dehors du
terrain je m'intéresse à rien en quoi il
ya une guerre en poids si je sais pas ce
que c'est la guerre le temps cadre
exclusivement grâce à tous et ça serait
bête qu'est ce que tu vas faire là ce
soir
maintenant la de la loire ouais tu es
dans une boîte tu vas retourner sur son
bateau regardez les sept étoiles qu'il
faut avoir vu avant ce soir tu vas tu
accroché pour les équipes 1 pourquoi pas
que tu les verras ce soir les sept
étoiles
et que tout est là on l'a vu qu'une
ouais ils ont dit demain il ya une page
web demain soir on verra ouais ouais il
ya des liens il ya eu une goutte il
tombe toujours à celle ci va l'horaire à
l'envi sortir et ouais je sais pas je
vais voilà c'est ça ouais le bateau
après oui bien sûr j'adore cela arrivera
oui et non il ya un type qui m'emmène ah
bon alors rien il ya un mec avec un
petit bateau qui m'emmène au bateau
annoncé organisée il peut m'arriver je
suis